[Music]
algorithm-based selection is really the
death of journalistic editing in every
way because inevitably the algorithm
just goes for the lowest common
denominator often very divisive very
sensational bit and that is different
from real engagement I mean everyone is
going to click on something which says
child murderer whatever I mean or
hateful politics or you just if the
human nature is such that you're going
to click on those things you know Bal
constrictor eats baby is just the
old-fashioned tabloid way in a sense of
catching bait but at the same time what
it's in the volume and the size and the
velocity that we're seeing now with the
digital platforms that has actually
pushed out everything else and what I
think is very very worrying is that
basically marketers have decided they
read don't want to be around news
because no surprise nobody wants to put
your their ad next to a flaming building
in Syria you know why would anybody want
to put their you know their beauty
products and something next to it they
don't want to be next to it so when you
disaggregate stories from from their
from their overall context you're not
going to find any any advertisers want
to be around the more serious
harder-edged kind of content so for me
that would have been like taking all the
great content out of Vanity Fair and
only putting the sensational media you
know celebrity stuff in it which really
wouldn't have been the product at all
but people like what people loved about
not any fair and they liked about all
the magazines I've done quality is that
mix of high-low that you actually are so
interested in the piece on on Demi Moore
or whatever it is that you then find
yourself engaged in and your curiosity
is awakened and then you go next to that
amazing piece of journalism about you
know the fall of some big political
figure or some interesting essay that
you wouldn't normally have read if you
disaggregate those things people are
just are just
read the sensational thing and they're
not going to read the other and that is
what is so tragic really and that is why
you keep seeing these huge layoffs that
have been happening recently again in
media and all the digital platforms that
we're supposed to have the answers
they're laying off all the journalists
that really wrote the content the real
stuff and instead just keeping the ones
who are doing the kind of the lighter
stuff the frothy stuff they're just
firing all the people who did the other
and that is very very threatening to our
whole democracy we had a little bit of
free Sun of excitement because we saw
Jeff Bezos buying the Washington Post
we've seen a great uptick in
subscriptions about the New York Times
we've seen Marc Benioff of Salesforce
buying time and so we think let's hope
that the digital billionaires now come
like the cavalry and kind of rescue the
the sort of charred husks of great media
companies but unfortunately every single
local outlet has been decimated because
they don't have that kind of rescue
available to them local news is just
closing down at the point that whole
cities have hardly any journalistic
policing which means that the malfeasant
powers can do whatever they wish no
one's going to cover them you're going
to see more corruption in government
you're going to see more uncovered
scandals that you know are allowed to
fester and damage people I think it's a
very very concerning time so I was
hoping that we'd like everyone I was
thrilled that those developments of the
people such as Bezos buying and he's
done an amazing thing I think supporting
the Washington Post that's great for
those major premiere outlets but
unfortunately journalism is comprised or
should be of many watchdogs in many
places and everybody but the big shots
are going down and that I think is a
very damaging thing and something that
we have to figure out how to combat
because advertisers have still decided
that Facebook and Google are the only
places worth advertising and until that
is changed by something that needs to
get done and if I pretended I have that
answer I would be Jeff basis probably
but it's a huge crisis that I think we
have to get addressed other
it's all going down
[Music]